salut aujourd'hui on lance un nouveau
concept qui s'est jamais fait sur
Internet c'est-à-dire je propose un défi
à des gens et si je perce des défis je
perds de l'argent
en gros il y a 15 abonnés qui sont avec
nous aujourd'hui salut
et qui sont venus pour prendre mon
argent le but du jeu est le suivant
derrière moi il y a 128 années de 1900 à
2027 les abonnés vont passer ici devant
moi ils vont me proposer une date en
piochant ici des mois des jours des
années soit qui choisissent soit au
hasard ils font ce qu'ils veulent il
faut que je retrouve quel jour de la
semaine tomber cette date-là précise si
j'y arrive pas il repartent avec 100
euros allez c'est parti pour perdre de
l'argent avant de commencer laissez-moi
vous préciser que ce genre de vidéo est
possible grâce au marquis sponsorise nos
vidéos et en particulier notre
partenaire du jour skin cher ce qu'il
cherche c'est une plateforme qui est
disponible en français et qui rassemble
une communauté de plus de 7 millions de
créatifs qui explorent alors rythme plus
de 25000 cours en ligne 25000 cours en
ligne dans des domaines passionnants
comme le graphisme la calligraphie la
photographie la production musicale
l'animation ça touche à tout parce que
oui il y a plein d'autres thématiques
par exemple beaucoup d'entre vous me
demandent régulièrement comment faire
pour mieux retenir leurs cours et je
vous parle souvent de la carte mentale
et bien sûr ce qu'il cherche vous avez
un cours
ultra passionnant en plusieurs chapitres
très qualitatifs qui est mené par
Catherine Madden et qui s'appelle la
pensée visuelle dessinée des données
pour communiquer des idées secours très
qualitatif je l'ai déjà dit mais quand
même je le répète vous donne tous les
outils pour mettre en place cette
technique là et s'en servir c'est
vraiment un corps qui est très détaillé
qui est très fluide n'hésitez pas à
jeter un coup d’œil sur lui
particulièrement mais la qualité elle
est normée sur la plateforme je trouve
tout très quali dessus la plateforme est
très agréable vous avez toujours toutes
les informations principales qui sont
indiquées de manière très claire la
durée du cours la durée des leçons la
possibilité d'activer les sous-titres en
français et sur ce qu'il cherche il y a
jamais de pub si cette aventure là elle
vous tente je vous mets le lien dans la
description parce que apprendre en
permanence se former en permanence c'est
important et les 1000 premières
personnes qui vont cliquer sur le lien
recevront un mois d'essai gratuit à ce
qu'il cherche donc soyez rapide
[Musique]
c'est maintenant autour de loups de
passer tu es très grand ou je suis très
petit les deux ok c'est sympa ça
commence bien je suis très très stressé
de ça 17 octobre 17 octobre 2000 je te
laisse passer derrière
17 octobre 2000 ça doit faire ça doit
faire
un mardi tout à fait
ça c'est bon tu sais quel jour tomber
Noël pour moi le 25 c'était un lundi
cette année-là tout à fait et voilà je
vais essayer de me mettre une dernière
difficulté parce que j'aimerais pas que
tu reparte les mains vides mais en même
temps si un petit peu si tu veux tu peux
me dire un
autre jour de cette année ce que tu veux
dans le 14 avril le 14 avril tu veux
dire le 14 04 ça c'est quand je gagne du
temps
le 14 04 c'est ça que tu veux me dire un
petit peu quoi oui bien sûr je me suis à
très bien le 14 04 ça tombait un
vendredi et oui oui donc tu as compris
le concept de la vidéo tu me dois 100 €
. donc c'est après ça peut être un rime
en cash ça marche alors personne
suivante
[Musique]
c'est le tour de Cassandra tu as une
année en tête ou tu vas prendre au pif
13 décembre ok 13 décembre 1936 allez
c'est parti comme ça j'ai envie de dire
que c'était un dimanche mais attends
laisse-moi un tout petit peu de temps je
reste je reste sur mon dimanche c'est
correct ou pas oui ok ça c'est déjà une
bonne chose la température extérieure
était de 23 degrés c'est correct
je vais essayer de te dire tous les
vendredis 13 qu'il y avait cette année
là il y avait pas de vendredi 13 en
janvier il y en a en février il y en a
en mars
non non il y en a du coup j'ai dit qu'il
y en avait un mars il y en a pas non
plus alors si on a en mars ah c'est une
année bissextile c'est ça bah bon bah
allez c'est bon je te dois 100 balles
[ __ ] viens Cassandra vient prendre
viens encaisser
personne suivante
[Musique]
alors Damien c'est parti je compte pas
perdre d'argent je te le dis ça va être
compliqué
année qui compte pour toi ouais jour qui
compte pour toi ouais le moi compte pour
toi c'est ça est-ce que ça t'a plu fait
cette session mentalisme le 3 le 3 mars
ok 2003
mardi et le 3 c'était un lundi c'est
vrai si je sais lire oui en plus
bon ben viens prendre ton argent mais
mais je le trouve pas très légitime ce
gars personne suivante
Nicolas vient me voir Nicolas je prépare
l'accessoire de beauté Loïc tout à
l'heure avant le tournage il m'a dit
mais t'as jamais remarqué j'adore te
mettre des trucs ridicules sur la tête
janvier 1922 le 4 janvier
1922 ça doit tomber un jeudi non pas du
tout j'ai pas dit ça
un mercredi en fait cette année-là parce
que c'est 1922 c'est mercredi ou pas ok
moi je propose que tu me demandes une
autre date de cette année-là 12 décembre
12 mardi oui bah désolé je te dois zéro
suivant
Anthony viens j'ai une proposition à te
faire tu joues pas je te donne 10 euros
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça part sur Mars ok 5 mars 92
jeudi
mais c'est un jeudi c'est un jeudi bien
sûr que c'est un jeudi est-ce que tu
veux que je te dise le jour de la
Saint-Valentin de cette année-là vas-y
ça tombe bien j'étais célibataire ce
jour-là c'était un samedi je m'en
souviens et non je sais pas si sûr tu as
vu c'est un quel jour
[Musique]
Tom on part sur du hasard on part sur du
quiconque pour toi on part sur une date
qui te rappelle un événement particulier
tu verras ok ça ça veut dire je ne parle
pas avec toi Fabien olicard si je suis
en 1954
pourquoi il est chaud celui-là 6 juin
si je juin 1954
dimanche exactement
j'étais pas si sûr tu peux m'emmener ton
6 juin dans le futur on n'a jamais
exploré le futur parce qu'en fait les
années futures n'ont pas été préparés
mais je sais que les calendriers y vont
plus loin là c'est chaud je suis jamais
allé dans le futur avec cet exercice 6
juin 2018
parce que en fait dans sa tête il habite
en 2017 en fait le futur c'était c'était
tout ce qui est plus loin que nous
pensons que 1954 ah oui non mais ça se
tient et bien on va partir sur un 6 juin
il est passé il est passé le 6 juin 2022
mais tu m'as dit qu'on a pas les cartons
après 2022 c'est ça sans les cartons et
puis on va partir sur un si je vois 2025
2025 OK
si je viens 2025 alors là Fabien tu te
tais tu réfléchis et tu trouves un
vendredi c'est exact
une chance sur 7
personne suivante
[Musique]
je te laisse composer la date Célia
c'est une date au hasard ou c'est une
date qui compte une date au hasard de
ton choix ou au hasard
est-ce que tu m'emmènes dans le futur ou
pas si tu veux Nathalie on se tente une
chauffe 29 août 2001 excellente date ça
c'est un mercredi
oui bien sûr c'était un mercredi 20
juillet 1967 c'est parti
jeudi oui ok 1959 c'est un dimanche oui
oui en janvier il y a un vendredi 13 oui
il y en a pas en février il y en a pas
en mars
1977 ça jeudi jeudi
27 OK
[Musique]
j'ai dit qu'il fallait que je me dépêche
vendredi
tu peux me dire n'importe quel autre
date de cette année si tu as le 14
juillet c'est mercredi c'est ça et non
mardi c'est un mardi ah merde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Victor le 11 novembre 1967
mais à 1900
5 6 vendredi pas du tout c'était samedi
j'ai dit vendredi mais c'est samedi
c'est ça
samedi donc je te dois rien du coup
puisque je l'ai précisé après en
deuxième ben non tu gagnes 100 euros
bien sûr Fabien était a voulu faire le
show c'est tout merci merci personne
suivante s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
tandis j'ai 10 secondes pour trouver ça
est-ce que c'est une vraie date une date
qui compte pour toi
c'est une vraie date est-ce que ça
existe les fausses dates le 32 juillet
2001 le premier novembre 2021
1 2 3 4 5 la 10 oui oui
personne suivante
[Musique]
Thomas Thomas tomate si je mets plus de
2 secondes il y a même pas besoin de
compter le 3 juillet quelle année 97
[Musique]
c'est un jeudi en fait quand la vache
puis là c'est la plus grosse plantate de
la vidéo quoi c'est pas lundi Anna c'est
mardi lundi c'est jeudi allez c'est bon
rentre chez toi personne suivante
[Musique]
Jonathan tu es la dernière personne on
va pousser le bouchon au maximum si tu
repars pas avec 100 € c'est que je suis
un génie
tu es un peu donc Jonathan cherche
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à cette
chaîne Youtube vous avez un bouton qui
est dédié à ça ça coûte pas 100 € c'est
gratuit de s'abonner donc n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner à cette vidéo et à dire
dans les commentaires ce que vous pensez
du concept j'ai plein d'autres idées on
pourrait décliner ça aussi je rate vous
gagnez 100 euros voilà si vous avez pas
envie de gagner 200 euros vous me le
dites aussi dans les commentaires on
part sur quoi sur le 22 c'est comme ma
date de naissance avril ça aurait pu
être ma date de naissance et non OK
[Musique]
allez vas-y on reste en 52 tu me changes
le jour où le mois ou les deux le 18
janvier le 18 janvier du coup de la même
année allez Fabien calme-toi 6 3 6 3 9 2
2 20 14 6 6 samedi
c'est correct et bien non c'était
bissextile vendredi non c'est vrai
je me suis auto fait avoir encore
mais attends mais j'ai un somme qui est
terrible ça
je suis un génie
je suis un génie je suis un génie je me
suis fait avoir par les années
bissextile vient chercher ton argent
merci encore à ce qu'ils cher d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo n'oubliez pas
toutes les informations sont dans la
description et si vous faites partie des
1000 premiers à cliquer dessus vous avez
un mois d'essai gratuit vous êtes venu
me dépouiller vous avez réussi en partie
tous ceux qui ont pas remporté 100 euros
vous m'avez laissé dans mon enveloppe
800 euros et ça c'est sympa on va tout
reverser une association qui s'appelle
dyspraxique mais fantastique donc une
association qui aide les enfants
atteints d'indice ça peut être de la
dyslexie de la dyspraxie etc etc qui
accompagne les enfants qui auraient du
mal par exemple à faire ce genre
d'organisation la mentale donc grâce à
vous on leur verse 800 euros vous pouvez
vous applaudir bravo
évidemment je vous mets un lien vers
l'association dans la description aussi
si vous voulez la découvrir ou la
soutenir faites-le avec le grand plaisir
merci d'être venu pour cette vidéo il y
a un lien dans la description pour vous
inscrire pour les prochaines vidéos on
mettra 100 balles en jeu contre un truc
de mentalisme à très bientôt Ciao